I was going to say so I got something
else sent to me here which is uh I guess
it's from Reddit it says like R4 slash
Bumble it says how do you find a man who
explicitly wants kids in the next two to
three years without scaring him off by
bringing it up too soon it's very short
I'll just read it very quickly she says
I'm 30 years old and have started to
want a child really badly so she's got
baby rabies right it always hits around
29 30. I'll do it alone but but live far
from family which is just [__] like
stop like these women that think that
they can raise a man or a woman by
themselves they're they're completely
out to lunch you know we've seen the
data on it I cover it in my book anyway
um I do it alone but live far from
family and just not wealthy enough sadly
I know bumble's paid version lets you
filter matches based on how they answer
the question about kids but a some still
answer that in a hypothetical Sunday way
and B some people do not say yes on
Bumble for different reasons but still
want them I don't like having to play
games of appearing not that interested
when this is my clear Five-Year Plan but
also have had not much luck asking
directly at it I live in New York City
it's a world in itself I've repeatedly
been told I'm far too young to have that
in my mind see that's that's feminism
telling her oh I'm far too young to have
that you're 30 okay like the window is
closing okay
anyway and it's terrible dating those
chicks too because they're negotiating
attraction my Five-Year Plan yeah that's
not how female attraction works and it
goes once you want her plan she wants
you on her plan she wants you to show up
with the money with the house with the
job pay for the wedding pay for
everything on her plan on her timeline
right you're going to you're going to
lose attraction as a man by doing that
you're not going to get a love you're
not going to get her respect she will be
stepping out of the marriage and again
it's the reason I get so amped up about
this is because good guys that know none
the wiser like just good stand-up
high-class dudes in terms like the moral
traditional sense these guys get [__]
[__] on following this stuff and the
women suffer too going back to Moss
Point if you look in like the comments
after I show it's always loser Anonymous
guys that have a problem with what we're
saying and if you look the women they're
100 in agreement how do I how do we know
this stuff because I hang out with a lot
of women and we talk about these things
and you understand very quickly when you
run volume what works and what doesn't
work and that I I'm sorry but I get
fired up about this stuff because then
guys saw the camera from us like hey man
I'm doing everything right and I'm not
getting ahead I'm like you got to pull
the [__] out of your head you just
have to do it I tweeted something the
other day that a lot of guys had a
problem with and Rich you retweeted this
and I was like there's a common problem
where and we saw this firsthand we had
the ladies night stream last Monday
where we had women that literally
affirmed what I said I said it's
interesting how as women get older and
the more baggage they pick up the higher
and more strenuous their standards get
we had two women that looked as dead in
the face and said yes I've gotten older
my standards have gotten higher and I
won't settle and people just came from
my neck in my comments it's like they
said it directly they didn't even skirt
around the issue they're talking to
women man I'm not just making this stuff
up and just spouting it off
nonsensically like it's the truth how
about our 10 shot last night one of the
new one of the newer kids that game he's
learning real quick like hey this
chick's a pain in the ass rich even
jumped on there leave her on red ignore
her she came right back changed her tone
real quick I posted a screenshot a
couple years ago now some girl I'm not
going to come straight to your house
especially in a foreign country left on
red four hours later hey I'm Keen to see
you do you want an f and the guy's like
that's how the game works guys stories
regarding that yeah lead your girls on
red listen
um no you said that their standards get
higher as they get older so what were
their standards before I'm I'm really
eager to know what were your standards
from 20 to 33 to 34. they must have been
really like the DJ the doors
exactly the same things and they're
younger they're screening for you know
husband and father stock as they get
older they're not screening for that
generally at 22 22 24. but I mean like
here's the thing like we've had several
weeks now these ladies night show and I
you know I think if anybody can take
anything from them it's like watch the
behavior watch the prior Behavior don't
always listen to what they're saying
you're going to start to see conflicts
especially when clarifying questions are
asked but a lot of these women you know
like we've had I think as young as 18 or
19 as old as these you know something
like that but and from all over the
world from all over the world and you
know I think that you know the one thing
that we've seen is like the women that
are at this stage like this 30 year old
stage you know where where they have
baby rabies where they're anxious and
they're like I have a two to three year
you know dating window and then a
five-year window to have kids so it's
two to three years to date to get the
ring to set up the party to get engaged
to do the photographs and the video and
then it's within five years I have to
have my first kid because it'll be 35.
like you know they have a plan in their
head right and it's like they first
again completely about everything else
about what it takes to be a good wife
and a good mother like they want the
party like they want to get married but
they don't always want to be a wife and
they don't always want to be a mother
because their plan then is you know
we'll have the babies and drop them off
at daycare right the question is framed
the wrong way the biggest problem is
this they're trying they're saying how
do I find a guy or how do which guy do I
look for that is going to give me what I
want instead of looking in the mirror
and saying how do I become a woman that
a guy wants to give children to that's
the biggest problem they're not looking
at themselves in the mirror saying at 30
years old how do I make myself as
attractive as possible if that dude is
hide over heels for you and wants you
and you're the [__] he will put kids in
you if that's what you know if that's
his ultimate goal the reason these women
are getting these lukewarm responses oh
I don't know not right now I don't want
to commit you're the problem what people
don't understand and what people are
afraid to look at themselves and really
know is that if someone doesn't want to
commit to you if somebody doesn't want
to move you out of the friend zone if
somebody if some guy doesn't want to
move you as a woman out of the
Friendship benefit Zone it's you it
isn't them it's not the fact that men
won't commit there's not this epidemic
of men that just want hookups they just
don't want you guys these women are not
these evil [__] who just want to run
on the CC and that just want to do all
this nonsense and Chase they just don't
want you and people are unwilling to
look at themselves and have that honest
conversation and fix it and Mom you you
that's an excellent point and back to
what you said earlier about you know and
rich said about you know a conference
that's coming up in our get-together in
Tampa and the other one of Florida if
you guys out there if you're listening
to this you're gonna go pay money to go
be a pickup artist I can train my dog
okay my dog's really dumb but I can
train him to get into his cage at night
you will become you'll pay money to be
to to get trained and how to pick up
ladies and then you'll have nothing else
you'll literally you'll literally be a
one-trick pony instead of you know
developing yourself and having them come
to you you'll just learn how to fool
people that's all right
yeah you can't retain them in them and
it goes exactly back to what I've said
the problem isn't the word why can't you
get it to do what you want you have to
do you have to improve yourself first
and then it'll come to you
yeah it's um you know it's a slippery
slope it's there's there's so many you
know they keep like two of the lies here
that this gal you know on this Reddit
post one she said
people keep telling me that I'm too
young to worry about this and two the
other [__] lie is well
I can do this on my own if I want or I
or I'd consider doing this on my own if
I want by default if she's entering the
conversation in the first paragraph
saying I can basically do this on my own
I don't need a guy
why is she shopping for a guy yeah
you've already lost she clearly doesn't
respect or value men or masculinity or
what a father would bring to the table
if she says that she can do this on her
own you know there's this whole movement
of single mother by choice like uh s m b
c like you'll see This Acronym like if
you Google SMBC or you put it in like
social media you'll see uh you know
things populate and you know it's the
same blind you know blind leading the
blind right like I Don't Need No Man a
woman needs a man like a fish needs a
bicycle sort of thing right but here she
is on a bumble Reddit asking how do I
get a guy to marry me within two to
three years you know because I'm 30
right like I feel my biological clock
ticking it's like
it doesn't matter what you do you know
you're setting yourself up for massive
you know potential failure that's
literally baby rabies right there yeah
like it's baby rabies and you know that
question on um Monday night I think
that's a good one to sort of table say
that yeah I think that's my one and and
the woman's the one who suffers right
there because the same way like guys
that come through us for coaching or in
the communities they they match a girl
on Tinder and they get over excited
they're over texting and they're hitting
her up and then they they push her away
by doing that that's weird that's odd
behavior and it's the same it's the same
thing that women do with the baby rabies
saying hey I don't want to date you
unless you're looking to get married in
one year they're putting pressure on you
it kills attraction for men for high
quality men it's funny because those are
the types of girls that make the rules
oh I gotta wait three dates whatever for
a high quality guys whenever a girl says
no hookups that means she's down to hook
up it's a screen test to filter you out
if you don't get it then you're not at
that level in game yet and then she gets
ran through she gets pumped and dumped
and in doing so she decreases her value
more she's a bit older she has one notch
count higher and and her standards go
higher with every Notch which is
hilarious how that how that inverse
Works to where it widens that Gap in
terms of her actual value and her
perceived value of herself and then guys
like us we have better options so like
yeah if a 30 if a 36 year old wants to
roll through and oh I'm looking for
marriage and no one-night stands she'll
come right over but I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna take her seriously that'll be
the younger girl the more feminine girl
the girl that falls more into my frame
that brings that unbridled femininity
into my life and not Jared we're on a
timeline Clark's chicken got to move
Gotta Move here's the next step that's
male energy and that turns guys off yeah
that's 100 accurate man 100 I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out